salut c'est omar je suis là pour x-men
des au futur past j'ai jou bishop dedans
allez le voir ses rangs bien c'est le
meilleur des x men
dans le prochain x men on est dans un
récent apocalyptique où les mutants sont
pourchassés par une sorte de robot qu'on
appelle les sentinelles qui arrive à les
détecter et ils sont programmés pour les
tuer je joue le rôle d'un mutant qui
s'appelle bishop et un délégué qui
combat ces sentinelles et qui va
finalement aidé wolverine à retourner
dans ce passé pour faire en sorte que le
futur soit meilleur c'est un très très
gros budget c'est un très gros film
c'est des moyens colossaux une technique
incroyable on avait un moniteur pour
chaque acteur on avait les caméras 3d
avec des grues dans tous les sens
n'avait tout un studio juste pour nous
mes costumes les accessoires les effets
spéciaux tout était sur place pour que
le réalisateur puisse avoir accès à tous
dans le même temps donc c'était juste
énorme
le meilleur souvenir dans tout ça c'est
le tournage en entier les journées que
j'ai passé à visiter les studios aller
voir les autres décors les autres
costumes je me suis donné le droit de
visiter tout ça c'était juste qu'ils
font parce qu'il ya des moments où je me
comportais un peu comme un fan je me
souhaite le vendredi jackman y venait
avec ces tickets à gratter
il en dise et but à tous à se petite
anecdote de tournoi quel bilan continue
à bosser sur mon anglais peut-être que
c'est ça le bilan
le fauteuil de professeurs et c'est
beaucoup plus facile à pousser que que
le fauteuil de france accusé parce que
pour le coup ils se poussent tout seul